good morning y'all
coffee chat
um
okay i hope my washer isn't too loud in
london
the washers and dryers are literally so
loud like it sounds like your apartment
actually it sounds like nothing i've
ever heard before but it's it's bad okay
well it's kind of hot okay so what are
we talking about today i'm gonna talk
about
something that happened to me this week
i decided to ask my dad for dating
advice
um
because i was like my dad's a smart guy
might as an interesting character
we like dan okay so
i'm asking him like how to find a
husband i'm like what should i look for
um and he was telling me some good
things he was like look where they're
going in life
um and then he said people change and i
was like that's kind of odd for my dad
because
as i've said before on the channel my
dad's kind of a pessimist okay i'm like
he's he's a really nice like person oh
gosh
but he's kind of like
should i put it
he doesn't have a lot of faith in people
and
he um he also like he doesn't really
like people like that's why he doesn't
come on my channel a lot of you guys
have asked
but no
my mom will probably come on my channel
she likes people but my dad just not not
a people guy he's like the type of guy
to get rich
um buy a big piece of land and hang out
with his family and like a couple close
friends on it which is what he does
and he's taught me a lot about dealing
with people actually anyways so one of
the things so when he said people change
i'm thinking dad
you're the last person to say that
you're the one who told me with my last
boyfriend like
people don't change so what was this new
what is this new epiphany for you he
said people change they get worse over
time
when you think about it that makes sense
like i think most people get
like
everything gets more pronounced because
the older you get i feel like
the tireder you become of like hiding
who you really are
the example i constantly use is me
drinking
most people drink more over time most
people get fatter over time
he was right
but my dad was dropping some gems i
asked him i was like dad can i date
actually i'm not gonna tell you that
part
i don't think my dad cancels because
he's kind of blood
um anyways
dad funniest guy but he here's his thing
with people i i've started this new
like trend in my life where he said
expect nothing from people
like when you hire someone expect them
to do a bad job and then when someone
does a good job you'll be really
grateful and thankful and you won't be
let down like
because my dad
is really good at hiring people and
managing people like that's always been
like
my dad my brother just started working
for my dad and he couldn't believe how
little coding my dad knows because my
dad is good at finding other people to
do it for him like he he's very much get
smarter people to do it
um
that makes sense he'll always okay okay
um he also would always tell me like you
don't have to get mad at people if they
let you down just stop dealing with them
and i started doing this in my life and
like
it was weird because they started
getting madder
like when you just don't deal with them
like they just like there's no point in
getting mad there's no point in like
getting frustrated just don't deal with
those people
so
um that's my morning coffee thoughts
let me know in the comments if you like
these let me know what you want me to
talk about next over coffee i do read
you guys comments i can't always respond
to all of them
because i just post so many videos that
it's like overwhelming to respond to
like
all of them but
i do read them so just know i read
probably close to every comment so
love you guys
love you so much
um and i'll talk to you guys next time